- "Why you should eat overripe bananas.
"A yellow skin banana with dark spots
"on it, it is eight times more effective
"in enhancing the properties
of white blood cells
"than green skin, than then".
Bro, what am, am I
reading something wrong?
What is happening here?
Hey guys, we've covered
medical memes before,
we've reacted to medical dramas,
but it never hit me to talk about some
of the crazy Instagram posts
that have to do with health.
I've seen a lot of those,
you've sent me them,
so I thought I'd react to some of them.
I feel like we're gonna be
in for a stressful video,
maybe a fun video.
A fun stressful video?
I'd dunno, let's find out.
Be-yoop!
Oh my God.
I'm just gonna read this as is,
because I feel like I'm
in the twilight zone.
"A yellow skin banana with
dark spots on it is eight times
"more effective in
enhancing the properties
"of white blood cells than
then green skin version.
"Eating 1-2 bananas a
day increases immunity."
(sighs)
That was just so stressful to read.
I feel like, whatever
health benefit you get
by eating a banana, it was fully negated
by reading this meme/Instagram post.
Can people eat bananas and
help their immune system?
Help support their immune system.
Boosting and over-boosting
your immune system's
actually a really bad thing.
Autoimmune conditions like
psoriasis, Crohn's disease,
of the intestines, that
cause really bad problems
for people, is an
over-boosted immune system
that starts attacking things that are
not actually a threat to you.
"Did you know?
"Once a week, for 20 minutes",
first of all, this is
a very lavish bathtub,
'cause there's clouds or
marshmallows, plus sticks.
And she doesn't quite fit in it.
"Once a week for 20
minutes, sit in a hot tub
"that contains a handful of Epsom salts,
"10 drops of lavender essential oil,
"and a half-cup of baking soda.
"This combo draws out
toxins, lowers stress,
"and balances your pH levels."
(clatters)
- Serenity now!
- The essential oil community's
trying to get me frustrated.
It does not balance your pH levels.
Can you imagine if an.
Your pH level is so tightly-controlled.
Like between 7.35 and
7.45 is its little range
that it lives in, and
if it comes out of that,
even slightly, like if
it goes to 6.9, you die.
Can you imagine in order to live,
you needed to take a bath
that looks like this?
That's a problem, folks.
You are not a dish.
Like if I was trying to
balance the pH levels
of my chicken in a pot, maybe
I'd wanna throw some lemon,
followed by baking soda on it.
But you, my friend, are not
a piece of chicken in a pot.
(laughs)
"Cashew.
"Good source or protein."
Is it a good source, or is it a protein?
We'll never know.
"Improve vitality, assit
metabolism function",
'cause you know, some our
metabolism function likes
to stand, and we like for it to sit.
"Prevent migraine headache.
"Lower risk of diabetes.
"Prevent gallstones.
"Fight heart disease."
Next time my patient
has a migraine headache,
or is about to get one, just gonna say,
"Hey, why don't you chill
out and get a cashew?"
Can you say it's a good source?
I don't know.
Like, what is considered
a good source of protein?
It is a source of protein.
Does it improve vitality?
What, like livelihood?
Like how happy you are?
Does it assit, does it assist
your metabolic function?
I mean, anything that you eat
assists metabolic function,
'cause your metabolism's
gonna start working.
Does it prevent a migraine headache?
That's ridiculous.
Throw it out there.
You know, though, I will say
something about cherries.
Cherries have natural aspirin in them.
Very small amounts, but some.
"Coconut, regulates thyroid function.
"Improves brain function.
"Maintain body mass.
"Stimulate immunity, keeps heart healthy.
"Improves digestion, full
of energy, glowing skin."
I don't know if they're
saying positive things
about coconuts, or this
is what's gonna happen
to you if you eat a coconut.
Like, is the coconut full of energy?
Does the coconut have glowing skin?
Is the coconut rich in fiber?
Kind of getting mad, here.
"Maintain body mass."
That's what food does, folks.
Have you ever eaten anything before?
I can put that on every label.
I'm pretty sure you could
put that on a pillow.
Like, I'm pretty sure if I
put this on this bear pillow,
it will maintain body mass.
(laughs) It probably won't.
But anything that's edible,
anything that has a calorie,
helps maintain body mass,
so that one is ridiculous.
"Regulates thyroid function", no.
You know what regulates thyroid function?
Thyroid-stimulating hormone.
It stimulates the thyroid to make hormone.
You know what stimulates
thyroid-stimulating hormone?
Thyroid-releasing hormone.
Glans, baby, not coconuts.
"For smelly underarms", God,
I don't even know where this is going.
Just, take a shower.
That's what I'm thinking.
Take a shower, bathe.
"Mix", ugh, it's a freakin'
science experiment.
My God, just wash yourself
and you won't have smelly underarms.
Can you imagine if you walk into my home
and you see I'm getting
ready for a hospital day,
and you see me measuring out coconut oil
and lemon juice in a teaspoon.
You ask me what I'm doing,
and then without any hesitation,
I just start throwing it on my armpits.
Would you judge me?
I don't know if this works.
Maybe I should experiment with it.
I don't think I have coconut
oil here, or lemon juice.
And their representation of
smelly underarms is like,
there's ribbons coming out of her armpits,
and she has red cheeks.
Maybe she has an infection.
Let's talk science for a second,
and leave this for a moment.
The reason why our
underarms actually smell?
Bacteria farts.
There's bacteria that generally
live in your armpit area,
and we can fight that bacteria,
because when that bacteria
starts consuming little things
that are on your skin surface,
it starts farting and smelling real bad.
And apparently I learned
something new today.
Lemon juice and coconut oil.
Might try it. Probably not.
"Did you know", that when it snows?
♪ Your eyes ♪
"Just by eating five dates in a day
"helps you reduce the
chances of night blindness,
"reduce hair loss, and risk of cancer.
"It also helps to improve your brain power
"and eyesight, because it is
high in fiber and potassium."
I feel like this meme is
screaming at me for some reason,
and this person's eye looks
like it has a cataract in it.
Google cataract.
That looks like a cataract.
Are people suffering,
like, I haven't had a date,
I haven't eaten a, I haven't
consumed a food known as a date
in probably five years.
Does that mean I'm at a high
risk of night blindness?
I think not.
I think that's not how life works.
"Did you know, eating
one to two figs soaked
"in water overnight helps
in faster weight loss
"as figs has high fiber
content, prevent wrinkles,
"makes your skin soft and supple,
"boost immune system, and
promote hair growth too."
Figs are a healthy food.
Do they prevent wrinkles?
No.
Do they make your skin soft and supple?
If your skin is not soft
and supple right now,
eating figs, randomly
introducing them into your diet,
probably won't change much.
Man, imagine life was that simple.
Like, my skin is rough.
I have two figs.
Now I'm supple.
"No more unwanted facial hair DIY."
"Papaya, before."
"Aloe vera gel, after."
(comical music)
Are they saying papaya makes you have hair
and then aloe vera gel does not?
Like, if you're gonna make a DIY,
you can't just put the
ingredients and go, "DIY."
What do I do?
Do you slap the papaya on your forehead
and eat the aloe vera gel?
All seriousness, this
looks like it would be
something targeted at females.
If you are a female, and
you're growing facial hair,
or hair in areas that
you haven't grown before,
and it's troubling to
you, you should go speak
with your family medicine doctor.
If it's happening in
combination with other symptoms,
that can be a sign of a
problem known as PCOS.
There's actually a medical
term for this unwanted type
of hair in a male pattern.
It's called hirsutism.
Don't be afraid to bring that
up in one of your visits.
I know some patients of mine
in the past have been hesitant
to bring it up, but please don't be.
It's something that happens.
It's treatable.
It depends, obviously,
on what's causing it,
but the answer is not a
papaya and aloe vera gel,
as much as that sounds delicious,
it's not the treatment.
"Doing this pose helps to double tap."
Oh.
"It helps to get rid of double chin,
"it increases the flexibility of the neck,
"provide a gentle
massage to belly organs."
This looks like just basic yoga cat-cow.
That's fine, I love cat-cow.
I recommend it to my patients.
I do it myself, I do it
in bed in the morning
when I wake up, but why is there a giant,
virus-looking bubble
(laughs) on this lady's back
when she's doing cow, or cat?
Is that a cow?
No, cats do this thing.
Or cats?
Do cows round their back?
Does it help to get rid of double chin?
I would say no.
Double chin can come from,
I guess, a few factors.
One is being obese.
You're gonna have more fat here.
You're gonna create the
appearance of a double chin.
If you have bad posture, I
guess you could have it, too,
but doing this alone
won't solve that issue,
so I'm not a fan.
"Two, increases flexibility of the neck."
I think it increases
flexibility of the spine,
and increases range of
motion, so I'm with that one.
They went neck, I'll
say spine, same thing.
"Provide a gentle
massage to belly organs."
Do you want to massage your belly organs?
You know the only organs
you might wanna massage
would be your intestines?
THere's actually certain
way that we can activate
your intestines, so if
you're like backed up,
there are certain massages that can help.
Also prenatal massages,
but massaging your liver?
I've never heard for that to be effective
in any sort of way.
Oh, it's not your liver, your
stomach, your gallbladder?
We'll massage that bladder nice (laughs).
Click here for my most
recent video on memes.
It's absolutely hilarious.
Or check out an older video
on how to not get sick.
I think it's more
applicable now than ever.
Which one you clicking?
Stay happy and healthy.
(funky music)